my creative process involves that old
saying about its ninety percent
perspiration and only ten percent
inspiration I struggle at every step of
the way it gets easy sometimes when I
know what it is I want to say what I
want to discover but it's always a
struggle so I'm very disciplined about
it I I have all kinds of mantras and
slogans and sayings i sometimes paste
them up on the wall around my various
computers they'll say just do it or the
famous quote i call it Cantor's law I
don't know if other people do but
Cantor's law everything can look like a
failure in the middle and so I'll say to
myself it's just the middle and I'll
paste up that quote because if you chip
away bit by bit eventually you have
created the Mona Lisa I mean what it
wasn't it Michelangelo and not the Mona
Lisa sorry stay there if you chip away
bit by bit you do create the great
sculpture I think it was Michelangelo
who once said how do you make this
beautiful sculpture he said well you
start with a block of stone and then you
chip away everything that isn't David so
in a sense it's at chipping away bit by
bit by bit having a big goal knowing
that it's got to be a big idea that it's
got to be something that is worth
reading that's the other thing the
creative process for me doesn't work as
well without an image of an audience in
mind who am I talking to Who am I doing
this for how is it going to effect or
influence them so it's that match
between the internal what's in me but
knowing who might receive it makes my
ideas a lot better than if I were simply
writing for an audience of two or
writing only for myself and I care about
that I I am an academic and a social
scientist and I have published in
academic journals and I could continue
to do it but I'm looking for bigger
things now I'm looking for impact on the
world for reaching audiences of the
powerful who
and do something with my ideas or
reaching audiences of the potential
future leaders and social entrepreneurs
who also can do something with my idea
but they start as anonymous ordinary
people and so if I have those in mind
and think about the impact and then just
discipline myself as difficult as it is
to just do it then the creative process
can be mastered but it's not like it's
easy
you